chers collègues
nous poursuivons les travaux de notre
mission d'information sur le
développement d'une filière de
biocarburant carburant synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert en recevant
cet après-midi monsieur Christophe
fanichet directeur président directeur
général de SNCF voyageur
j'ai pas entendu l'explication entre
voyageurs et
je suis
je salue également les personnes qui
accompagnent monsieur fannychet madame
Carole Desnos directrice technologies
innovation et projet du groupe SNCF
président du Conseil d'orientation pour
la recherche et l'innovation des
industries du ferroviaire monsieur
Vincent Delcourt
directeur performance stratégique et
intelligence tech du groupe SNCF pilote
du cluster innovation énergie monsieur
Stéphane
faclick
merci pour indice lexique c'est dur
responsable de la décarbonation de la
flotte Tom Bruno Souchon
directeur du cabinet de cabinet adjoint
du président directeur général de la
SNCF voyageur et Madame Laurence Nyon
conseillère parlementaire du groupe SNCF
je rappelle que cette réunion est captée
elle est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat sur laquelle elle
pourra ensuite être consultée en visio à
la demande monsieur le Président
Directeur Général mesdames et messieurs
notre mission d'information comprend des
membres issus des différentes
commissions du Sénat et qui représente
l'ensemble des groupes politiques de
notre le développement des filières de
biocarburant carburant synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert sera l'un des
éléments importants de la décarbonation
des transports et donc l'une des voies
pour atteindre les objectifs ambitieux
que c'est fixé assigné l'Union
européenne à travers au travers du pack
vert et du paquet ajustement à
l'objectif 55 le secteur du transport
ferroviaire apparaît à de nombreux
égards vertueux sur le plan des
émissions de carbone et pourtant en
dépit du progrès important concernant
l'électrification du réseau au cours des
années il reste encore près de 43% du
réseau TER qui n'est pas électrifiée et
sur lequel roulent des locomotives
fonctionnant pour l'essentiel avec un
moteur diesel le sujet de la
décarbonation du transport ferroviaire
n'est donc pas anecdotique et vous
pourrez nous délivrer votre vision des
enjeux permet aussi peut-être des marges
de manœuvre que vous imaginez en termes
de capacité de rapport modal au profit
du transport ferroviaire de nouvelles
technologies apparaissent et la SNCF a
expérimenté de nouvelles rames 10 modes
fonctionnant à la fois l'électricité et
à l'hydrogène cette voie vous
apparaît-elle mature sur le plan
technologique mais aussi raisonnable sur
le plan financier tant pour la SNCF que
pour les collectivités depuis 2021 la
SNCF conduit également une
expérimentation sur les trains opérants
la ligne Paris-Granville qui roule au
B100 quel est votre retour d'expérience
envisagez-vous un déploiement plus large
des biocarburants pour le transport
ferroviaire notre rapporteur monsieur
Vincent capo canelas qui est à l'origine
de notre mission vous a adressé un
questionnaire que vous pouvez vous
servir comme guide mais
vous intervenez comme vous l'entendez je
passerai ensuite la parole à notre
rapporteur puis à l'ensemble de mes
collègues afin qu'ils puissent vous
relancer et vous poser un certain nombre
de questions vous pourrez nous
transmettre
ultérieurement les réponses écrites aux
questions que vous a adressé notre
rapporteur monsieur fannychet je vous
passe où je vous cède la parole
merci infiniment monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs permettez-moi de
boire de vous remercier de m'avoir
invité en tant que PDG de Senseo
voyageur je vais dire exactement ce qui
est SNCF voyageur puisque effectivement
de depuis 3 ans par la loi nous sommes
maintenant en société et c'est pour moi
un honneur ainsi que l'ensemble des
collègues du groupe SNCF d'être devant
vous pour exprimer
ce que nous pensons pour le groupe SNCF
du sujet que vous avez évoqué pour nous
c'est un sujet absolument majeur
et je pèse mes mots parce que c'est la
nécessité pour nous de dessiner une
stratégie de développement d'une filière
de carburant non fossiles pour
contribuer à la décarbonation du secteur
des transports on sait que dans notre
cas le transport représente une part
très importante du carbone ennemi et
donc c'est pour cette raison que pour le
groupe SNCF on vous remercie infiniment
de nous laisser l'occasion d'exprimer
notre vision sur ce sujet alors SNCF
voyageur aujourd'hui c'est le leader du
transport des carboné véritablement un
acteur de transport de masse alors en
quelques mots SNCF voyageur c'est une
entreprise de transport ferroviaire de
voyageurs qui est né le 1er janvier 2020
avec l'entrée en vigueur de la loi pour
le nouveau pacte ferroviaire chaque jour
bon nombre d'entre vous le savez déjà ce
sont près de 15000 trains de SNC
voyageurs qui circulent sur le réseau
ferroviaire mais dont j'aime à rappeler
qu'il s'agit de 14000 trains du
quotidien assuré par les activités TER
et Transilien 8000 TER et un peu plus de
6000 Transilien pour à peu près 4
millions et demi de voyage quotidiens
les voyages en TGV représentant entre
1/2 millions et 700 000 voyages
quotidiens alors chez SNCF voyageurs
nous souhaitons vraiment réaffirmer que
la meilleure solution pour se déplacer
tout en protégeant la planète et on
baissant les gaz à effet de serre c'est
tout simplement de monter à bord d'un
train alors chaque année le transport
ferroviaire de voyageurs permet d'éviter
les émissions de gaz épais de serre
d'environ 12 millions de tonnes CO2 qui
auraient été émise par des villes
voitures individuelles moi j'aime à
comparer les choses et je trouve que la
voiture individuelle en est une
démonstration ce qui place SNCF
voyageurs comme le leader du transport
décarboné de masse en France en effet le
ferroviaire et le moyen de transport
dont l'empreinte environnementale et la
plus faible comparativement à la voiture
et à l'avion
quelques chiffres pour bien comprendre
l'écart entre le train mode de transport
collectif et des carboné et les autres
modes de transport
voyager en train c'est réduire de 98%
ces émissions de CO2 par rapport à un
voyage en avion et 93% par rapport à un
voyage en voiture thermique et enfin 80%
par rapport à un voyage en voiture
électrique voyez j'ai en train c'est
donc 11 fois moins d'énergie consommée
qu'un voyage équivalent en avion 6 fois
moins qu'en voiture thermique et jusqu'à
deux fois moins qu'en voiture électrique
les émissions de CO2 du passager d'un
TER sont en moyenne inférieure à 24 g de
CO2 par kilomètre si on le compare à la
voiture
l'automobiliste s'élève à 150 g de CO2
par kilomètre ce mode de transport
vertueux permet aujourd'hui à SNC
voyageurs d'émettre moins d'1% des
émissions de CO2 du secteur des
transports
en réalisant plus de 10% des trajets
l'objectif de SNCF voyageur en tant que
représentant d'un groupe public et
d'aller plus loin et de convaincre les
automobilistes de laisser leur voiture
au garage pour prendre le train
je dirais laisser la voiture au garage
j'irai peut-être que on peut pas
abandonner la voiture c'est pas du tout
notre objectif mais je pense qu'on peut
envisager d'abandonner la deuxième
voiture
c'est pour être conforme à notre nature
et notre raison d'être que nous sommes
fixés un double objectif rappelé par le
président du groupe Jean-Pierre phare
randou c'est de multiplier par deux la
part modale du fever tout en réduisant
dans le même temps de 30% nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre d'ici 2030 pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone en 2050
car si le train est majoritairement
électrique vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
le Président il ne l'est pas
exclusivement le réseau ferroviaire est
électrifié à 60%
et sur ses 60% on a 94% de notre trafic
ferroviaire de passagers il reste donc
16% c'est 16% sont effectuées
effectivement au gazole pour assurer ces
circulations ou n'avons pas de ktmr
électrique et nous avons engagé pour
notre groupe depuis plusieurs années une
politique énergétique très ambitieuse
qui passe notamment par la décarbonation
en développant des solutions de
substitution aux énergies fossiles
43% des 800 000 tonnes d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre de Senseo voyageur
proviennent de l'utilisation des trains
thermiques et bimode il s'agit pour la
plupart des trains qui circulent sur les
lignes de dessert fin du territoire là
où les voyageurs sont moins nombreux et
où en conséquence les travaux
d'électrification des lignes ne sont pas
économiquement pertinent sur ce point
ayant en tête que les circulations
carbonées concernent des services
régionaux assuré par les 585 trains à
moteur thermique et les 540 trains
bimode thermique et électrique de
l'activité TER de SNC voyageurs dans ce
cas TER le délégataire d'un service de
transport concédé et financé par les
autorités organitrices de transport mais
fort de notre expertise nous travaillons
à leur côté pour leur conseiller les
accompagner vers une décarbonation en
lien avec les industriels de la filière
ferroviaire et j'imagine que vous aurez
des questions sur ce sujet
pour notre part nous sommes convaincus
qui n'existe pas une solution unique de
décarbonation
mais que chaque territoire selon ses
besoins de mobilité ses spécificités
requiert la mise en place d'une
technologie de décarbonation adaptée
pour cela SNCF a développé une
méthodologie innovante que nous avons
appelée diagan match pour accompagner
les territoires dans leur choix de
technologie de décarbonation la plus
adaptée mais en définitive ce sont les
régions qui choisissent la politique
environnementale et les choix
économiques et budgétaires afférents
qu'elles veulent appliquer sur leur
territoire il nous faut donc trouver des
solutions à même de les convaincre pour
les rassurer sur le planctique aussi
bien que économique alors fort
heureusement la SNCF voyageur peut
s'appuyer au sein du groupe SNCF sur la
direction des technologies et
d'animation représentaient mes côtés par
Carole desnault que vous avez rappelé
monsieur le Président l'innovation et
vous le savez dans notre groupe nous
innovons en permanence va jouer un rôle
déterminant pour identifier les
solutions qui vont permettre de
renforcer la performance du système
ferroviaire et favoriser la transition
énergétique l'expertise de direction des
technologies de l'innovation nous
permettent d'engager et de construire
avec les territoires des solutions
pérennes pour nous diriger
collectivement vers la décoration de
toute cette filière
ces travaux nous permettent aujourd'hui
d'identifier plusieurs solutions vous en
avez évoqué quelques-unes la première
d'entre elles qui concerne au premier
chef votre mission d'information est
déjà utilisée par SNCV voyageur ce sont
les biocarburants
depuis plus de deux ans il faut le
rappeler depuis plus de deux ans en
partenariat avec la région Normandie
c'est déjà 5 millions de kilomètres qui
ont été parcourus sur la ligne Paris
Granville avec des trains alimentés en
biocarburant cela a permis d'éviter les
émissions de près de 16000 tonnes de CO2
mais rappelons ici que nous sommes très
vigilants sur le respect des critères de
durabilité des biocarburant qui doivent
être certifiés par des organismes
indépendants les burc carburants
représentent une solution de deck
carbonation qui peut être mise en place
rapidement souvent dans ce sujet de
décarbonation on a pu voir des solutions
à plus long terme je le dis fortement et
vous allez le voir tout au long de mon
propos les biocarburants c'est
maintenant et ça fonctionne dès
aujourd'hui 5 millions de tringles ont
déjà été effectués le passage au
biocarburant permet bien sûr de réduire
nos émissions de CO2 de plus de 60% par
rapport au gazole ferroviaire
c'est certes une solution transitoire
mais qui présente l'avantage d'être
possible de mettre en oeuvre dès
maintenant et qui comporte malgré tout
encore vous le verrez quelques
contraintes logistiques de
ravitaillement d'autres solutions sont
développées conjointement avec la
direction des technologies de
l'innovation de la SNCF et les régions
il s'agit d'abord du TER hybride vous
l'avez évoqué le train bimode sur lequel
50% de la monorisation thermique en un
mot tout ce qui est au gasoil a été
remplacé par des batteries
couplée à l'utilisation de biocarbures
en baissant doit permettre d'atteindre
une réduction des émissions de l'ordre
de 70%. et une réduction de la
consommation d'énergie jusqu'à
20%. l'expérimentation de ces fameux TER
hybrides débutera à la fin de cette
année en partenariat avec les quatre
régions qui ont souhaité s'investir dans
ce projet je parle de la région Grand
Est
Occitanie nouvelle et Aquitaine et
centre Val de Loire et ce train hybride
va circuler sur ces quatre régions parce
que du différentes géographies et
profils de voix sont importants pour
voir sa pertinence en complément nous
allons expérimenter sur une autre série
de trains régionaux le remplacement de
l'intégralité de la monotorisation
thermique par des batteries ça sera du
100% batterie
cette premier train à batterie seront en
circulation à la fin de l'année 2024 en
partenariat là également avec 5 régions
Occitanie nouvelle-aquitaine région sud
haut de France et Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
concernant l'hydrogène sur lequel vous
m'avez interrogé le groupe SNCF est
engagé depuis 2018 au côté d'Alstom et
le 4 régions françaises Grand Est
Bourgogne Bourgogne Franche-Comté
Auvergne et Occitanie dans un programme
de conception et d'acquisition de 12
rames Regis hydrogène c'est très
circuleront d'ici 2025 avec une
expérimentation sous le contrôle de mes
collègues entre Montréjeau et éluchon
au-delà des premiers choix
technologiques qui ont été réalisés le
véritable défi pour l'hydrogène c'est le
modèle économique les coûts
d'investissement dans l'acquisition des
nouveaux matériels de l'installation des
stations mais également les coûts
d'exploitation notamment le prix de
l'hydrogène décarbonée sont à ce stade
trop élevé pour mettre pour permettre
une véritable déploiement à grande
échelle
pour répondre à ce défi il sera
nécessaire de trouver des synergies
entre les différents besoins locaux
transports et industriels pour
mutualiser les investissements et
massifier les volumes consommés en ce
sens le groupe SNCF étudie les synergies
aux bornes des activités du groupe on
s'associant pardon en associant le
besoin des activités ferroviaires mais
également routière avec nos deux
filiales lisses et Geodis enfin je vais
aborder rapidement la question du
if you
ce carburant de synthèse qui se place en
concurrence directe avec les
biocarburants de notre point de vue
cette filière ne présente pas une
maturité industrielle suffisante pour
constituer une solution par ailleurs la
production de ces carburants de synthèse
demandera des investissements très
lourds et le coût au litre attendu
devrait rester un désavantage majeur
pour la promotion de cette solution
auprès des autorités organisatrices de
transport
nous ne sommes pas les seuls acteurs de
cette transformation profonde et avant
pour cela le besoin d'appui de nos
partenaires industriels et
institutionnels à titre d'exemple la
filière biocarburant doit être robuste
et nous garantir une sécurité
d'approvisionnement et le développement
d'une filière batterie ferroviaire
mature est indispensable pour développer
les technologies des carbonées posts
biocarburant biocarburant c'est une
solution pour nous qui est transitoire
avant d'arriver aux autres solutions que
je viens de décrire
alors quels sont nos besoins et nos
attentes c'est la question que vous
m'avez posée
un autre sens pour accélérer la
transition énergétique des scénarios
sont construits sur le long terme avec
les autorités ganitrices de transport la
réalisation de cette trajectoire et sa
réussite sont conditionnées au
financement des solutions jugées
pertinentes
prioritaire tant du point de vue du
matériel roulant que du point de vue de
l'infrastructure l'État devra favoriser
le développement des filières en créant
un cadre réglementaire favorable
nos besoins pour les biocarburants
aujourd'hui deux obstacles contraignent
le déploiement des biocarbures dans le
secteur ferroviaire le premier obstacle
concerne la réglementation applicable
aux infrastructures de distribution des
biocarburants la réglementation par
exemple interdit la construction de
station de distribution polycarburant et
la mixité des produits est interdite
dans les réservoirs de notre 1
cela est un frein majeur à
l'optimisation de la distribution et par
ailleurs chaque entreprise ferroviaire
doit disposer de ses propres
installations de distribution et de
stockage dédiés alors qu'elles sont
partagées et réguler aujourd'hui une
simplification de la réglementation est
indispensable au développement des
biocarburants pour le système
ferroviaire
nous sommes à la disposition pour vous
apporter les précisions nécessaires sur
ce point le second obstacle
tout le monde le vous l'aura déjà dit je
pense c'est le prix en raison d'un coup
de la matière plus élevé les
biocarburants sont plus coûteux que le
gazole cette différence pourrait être
atténuée par la fiscalité or celle
appliqué au biocarburant et soit
identique à celle du gazole soit la
différence appliquée trop faible
qui a pour effet de maintenir un écart
de prix au détriment des biocarburants
la mise en place d'une fiscalité
vraiment incitative voire nulle pourrait
faciliter le déploiement des
biocarburants
enfin et j'en termine par là
nos besoins pour nous sont d'abord des
besoins de nouvelles technologies SNCF
est pleinement engagé dans le
développement de solutions rupture pour
atteindre les objectifs environnementaux
au travers du développement des
premières flottes de train des carbonées
nous aurons décidé fin 2025 mis en
service un premier portefeuille de
solutions de décarbonation 2023 pour les
trains hybrides 2024 pour les freins
batteries et 2025 pour les trains
hydrogène et des solutions
d'électrification frugale l'enjeu se
situera dans le passage à l'échelle et
dans l'industrie réalisation de ces
solutions pour l'instant nous en sommes
les expérimentations le passage à
l'échelle sera véritablement déterminant
pour nous pour accélérer cette
transition il est indispensable que les
pouvoirs publics sécurisent les aides
nécessaires au financement des surcoûts
d'investissement
en conclusion je pourrais résumer mon
propos et mes messages en trois points
d'abord vous l'avez bien compris le
train est le mode le plus décarboné par
excellence il est déjà existant
il a déjà fait ses preuves et donc
soutenir le ferroviaire c'est agir
directement en favor en faveur du mode
le moins émetteur
et cela maintenant le deuxième point
c'est que pour accélérer notre
décarbonation nous avons devant nous un
bouquet de solution vous l'avez vu je
l'ai bien de les décrire que nous
développons au service des régions et
nous y croyons et enfin le biocarburant
et la solution de court terme permettant
un effet de décarbonation immédiat sans
avoir à recourir d'importants
investissements et je rappelle c'est 60%
de
CO2 en moins pour autant comme vous
l'avez noté nous avons besoin d'un
effort sur la fiscalité
voilà les derniers propos que je
souhaitais vous présenter je vous
remercie pour votre écoute et avec
l'ensemble de l'équipe Carole Denault
vincend Delcourt Stephane chahuck et
moi-même sur votre disposition pour
répondre à l'ensemble des questions
merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de SNCF voyageur merci d'abord
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation et
vous êtes un acteur majeur vous dites
effectivement leader sur le transport
des carbonées de masse votre analyse
votre expérience et pour seront pour
nous très très précieuses vous abordez
d'abord l'objectif de neutralité carbone
de SNCF en 2050 alors vous avez dit un
stand de choses vous pouvez nous redire
en quelques mots les uns et les autres
comment comment vous y arrivez en
partant du constat d'aujourd'hui et quel
est l'ampleur de l'effort à faire pour
vous de votre point de vue alors la peur
de l'effort à faire c'est en gain de
décarbonation mais peut-être aussi si
vous pouvez nous situer je sais pas si
vous avez cet élément là ici les
communicables mais l'ampleur de l'effort
financier a conduire là-dessus parce que
c'est un point qui est quand même
important puis deuxièmement vous avez
évoqué les différents niveaux
d'émissions et les comparaisons que vous
faites en termes de CO2 entre les
le mode j'ai noté par exemple pour le
pour la voiture thermique que vous
émettez 93% de moins bon alors si on
pondèrent ça par le fait qu'il y a quand
même une partie 16% du réseau qui
fonctionne au gazole est-ce que ces
chiffres sont les mêmes si on raisonne
en globalisant en tenant compte dans
l'ensemble du réseau et d'une part qui
fonctionnent au gazole ou est-ce que
c'est uniquement sur les lignes
électrifiées qu'on fait ce comparatif
premier élément et deuxièmement si on
raisonne sur l'ensemble de du cycle
entre guillemets c'est-à-dire en
intégrant le l'effet en émission de CO2
des infrastructures
qu'est-ce que ça change de ce point de
vue là
ça c'est mon premier premier blog de
questions et puis deuxième bloc très
rapidement on a entendu vos propositions
sur centrer spécifiquement sur les voici
assez largement pardon sur les
biocarburants donc c'est la partie qui
est clair et que et que qu'on entend
parce que ça ça fonctionne comme vous
l'avez très bien dit je crois j'ai noté
votre formule c'est maintenant et ça
fonctionne ça me paraît effectivement
juste
du coup il y a deux il y a deux deux
points qui sort sur la réglementation et
sur le prix voilà si vous pouvez
peut-être un peu mieux nous développer
ces deux suggestions parce que pour la
mission ça sera important de de bien
saisir quelles sont vos attentes sur ces
deux points
alors plus plusieurs questions
comment on arrive jusqu'à la neutralité
carbone jusqu'en 2050 que je vous
propose c'est que de façon écrite on
vous donne les différentes étapes
dans nos travaux sauf sirole tu veux
apporter ce complément moi ce que je
voulais vraiment présenter devant vous
aujourd'hui c'est que notre entreprise
n'est pas attendre ce qui se passe faite
par d'autres mais on veut absolument sur
les 16% du réseau ferroviaire trouver
des solutions alternatives c'est-à-dire
comment on fait pour ne pas avoir à
mettre un fil caténaire et électrifier
la ligne c'est un million d'euros du km
pour électrifier une ligne et donc on
n'a pas toujours les moyens j'entends
les autorités organitrices ou l'état de
faire cette électrification c'est pour
cette raison qu'on a proposé un bouquet
de solution le biocarburant n'est pas
dans la neutralité carbone on est sur
l'hydrogène ou la batterie
sur ce point là peut-être Carole tu
pourras tu pourras développer ainsi que
l'ensemble des chiffres qu'on vous a
donné ces chiffres qui sont ceux de
l'ADEME c'est pas des chiffres de
l'entreprise c'est-à-dire que les
calculs qui ont été faits sont ceux qui
ont été faits au travers de ce que nous
a été mis par la dame et on nous on
souhaitait que ça ne soit pas donné par
le groupe SNCF parce que évidemment ça
serait donné la caution et c'est pour
cette raison que c'est les chiffres de
la DM qu'on vous donne et non pas et non
pas et non pas ceux du groupe peut-être
si tu peux apporter les éclairages
bonjour
à tous monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur donc effectivement je dirais
que la première la première orientation
pour nous étant donné qu'on est
majoritairement décarboné c'est
d'arriver à sortir du diesel donc la
sortie du diesel elle va se faire
progressivement la particularité qu'il y
a dans le ferroviaire c'est qu'on a
aussi une durée de vie importante sur le
matériel donc c'est important de
d'utiliser la durée de vie du matériel
parce que ça évite de réinvestir du
matériel neuf et de d'utiliser des
matières premières donc la sortie du
diesel elle peut se faire de plusieurs
manières soit on change le carburant et
effectivement comme la développer le
président faniché les biocarburants on y
a travaillé depuis quelques années et
présente une alternative intéressante
parce que avec peu de modification sur
les moteurs avec peu de conséquences sur
la maintenance on arrive à
abonner à plus de 60% le
taux de carbone en utilisation classique
en plus vous pourrez revenir mais je
dirais que les biocarburants ils ont ils
ont l'avantage en France
d'être disponible de ne pas être en
concurrence avec la partie agricole et
d'être sur le plan environnemental un
plus pour le pays et on va être dans une
situation où aujourd'hui la
réglementation prévoit dans le B7 de
MATV 8,4% de biocarburant or on sait que
l'utilisation de biocarburant pour le
carburant routier va baisser
progressivement avec la réduction des
véhicules diesel et puis avec même
l'extinction des véhicules diesel et ça
va correspondre justement à la période
pendant laquelle on aura nous un besoin
croissant de biocarburant puisque nous
on parle pas de B7 mais on parle de
Bessan donc on mettra 100% de
biocarburant
et là encore c'est vrai que c'est
maintenant et ça fonctionne parce que
techniquement les résultats sont là on a
une petite baisse de puissance mais mais
globalement ça peut se compenser par
d'autres d'autres aléas techniques donc
les biocarburants c'est vraiment une
solution qui va permettre de sortir
rapidement du diesel avec les choix qui
seront fait au niveau des régions les
autres choix ça pour apporter sur du
retrofit de matériel avec des batteries
donc soit du train hybride le train
hybride on y travaille aussi depuis
quelques années et le train hybride et
techniquement prêt à être déployés c'est
une question de moi et puis derrière on
aura un peu comme ça c'est fait je
dirais dans dans d'autres secteurs on
passera le d'hybride au Full batterie et
puis et puis à l'hydrogène alors
l'important j'irai sur les biocarburants
c'est c'est vraiment de pouvoir démarrer
et de viser cette progressivement cette
neutralité carbone alors on pourra
réécrire le schéma de la neutralité
carbone ça dépend aussi il faut voir le
type de matériel qu'on a le taux de
renouvellement sauf si Stéphane tu peux
donner quelques quelques éléments mais
on a cette Neutra on a un plan d'action
sur les neutralités carbone mais
vraiment je pense qu'il faut retenir que
c'est on le dit souvent entre nous mais
des dix ans qui viennent sont vraiment
des années de croissance du ferroviaire
tel qu'on a pu le connaître il y a
plusieurs décennies parce que il y a
cette urgence climatique et que les
technologies dans le domaine ferroviaire
peuvent être déployés le principal frein
est un frein économique sur la fiscalité
des biocarburant sur des coups de
rétrophytes et c'est là le principal
frein sur des coûts de distribution que
ce soit biocarburant ou hydrogène mais
globalement techniquement on n'est pas
dans une remise à plat complet des choix
technologiques je dirais que les
orientations technologiques qui ont été
prises il y a déjà fort longtemps dans
le ferroviaire de passer au Full
électrique
se retrouvent aujourd'hui être les
bonnes solutions puisque
l'électrification quand on dit qu'on
électrifiait après de 70% et que le
reste on ne l'a pas fait pour des
raisons économiques je pense que ça
c'est vraiment important avant de passer
la parole pour la neutralité carbone
assez fan je phallique je dirais que le
point important c'est de dire que tout
le travail qui a été fait justement de
développer plusieurs solutions
technologiques et de pouvoir décider
avec les régions le choix des meilleures
solutions technologiques en fonction des
profils d'utilisation en fonction des
industries déjà présentes est-ce que la
région est plus agricole est-ce que la
région est plus industrielle ça va
permettre de à la France de développer
du ferroviaire des carbonés de sortir du
diesel de pouvoir réopérer plus de
trains sur ces petites lignes à moindre
coût et on a de l'avance sur sur ce
domaine là par rapport aux autres pays
européens
quelques quelques éléments de précision
sur la stratégie de décarbonation il
faut schématiquement avoir en tête qu'il
y a deux horizontaux une échéance plutôt
plutôt courte donc ça doit être vraiment
agir à court terme on a parlé beaucoup
des solutions de décarbonation mais on
est évidemment aussi engagé dans des
solutions de sobriété énergétique par
des gestes en opérationnels comme le
petit conduite donc c'est l'optimisation
du geste métier des agents de conduite
et puis les Quest stationnement donc on
souhaite agir vite et donc cette
réduction envisagée participe déjà aussi
une forme de décarbonation même si elle
n'est que partielle et puis il y a les
biocarburants qui est une solution très
rapide très rapide parce qu'elle ne
nécessite vraiment que très peu de
modifications sur le matériel roulant le
surcoût est assez contenu et on a
quelque chose qui fonctionne qui est
dans notre portefeuille de solution
et puis un horizon un petit peu plus
lointain c'est ce sont les nouvelles
technologies mais tu pourrais juste dire
combien ça coûte de passer au
biocarburant c'est quelques milliers
d'euros oui matériel roulant pour qu'il
passe du gazole actuel au biocarburant
c'est 10000 euros c'est ça c'est environ
5000 euros par RAM pour des surcoûts de
des surcos de maintenance faut changer
les filtres il faut changer les
flexibles donc le surcoût en maintenance
est assez limité le surcoût en énergie
lui il est quand même réel puisque
on est à plus plus 15% aujourd'hui mais
on a espoir qu'avec le développement de
la filière et ben c'est cool se
rapprochent au final du coup du gazole
non routier mais on a quelque chose dans
nos mains qui est assez précieux et qui
peut être rapidement dégainé pour
pouvoir décarboner des carboner de façon
assez ample notre parc de matériaux et
puis le sujet du plus long terme
aujourd'hui il faut vraiment avoir en
tête que les premières circulations qui
vont venir afin 2023 pour l'hybride afin
de vivre 24 pour le train batterie et
afin 2025 pour l'hydrogène ce sont
aujourd'hui des circulations pilotes qui
vont nous permettre de nous tester de
définir les zones de pertinence de
chacune de ces technologies et pourquoi
on veut faire cela c'est pour pouvoir
définir avec précision la performance de
chacune de ces solutions en fonction et
ça a été dit des ressources du
territoire en fonction des contraintes
de l'exploitation et de l'infraction de
l'infrastructure de l'infrastructure
Parmentier existe déjà donc c'est aussi
important de se dire que c'est
aujourd'hui on œuvre pour l'exploitation
future sur ces nouvelles technologies
avec cela on arrive à atteindre
effectivement les objectifs de SNCF de
zéro émission nette à horizon 2050 on
n'a pas été précis dans mon réponses
donc je vais les reformuler
bon il y a trois stades Bessan batterie
H2
c'est très clair Besson vous a dit qu'on
savait le faire
Besson on vous a dit que
l'adaptation des matériels roulants
c'était quelques milliers d'euros pour
pouvoir les adapter
baissons vous a dit que si ça croisait
assez vite le surcoût pourraient être
atténué plus les éléments dont je vous
ai fait part ça c'est la première partie
la deuxième partie pourquoi on est
évasif et sur batterie sur hydrogène
d'abord cette technologie elles sont pas
complètement matures même si elles sont
suffisamment avancées bien plus avancé
que le ifuel elle ne le sont pas assez
au titre du groupe SNCF on a vraiment
besoin de faire ces expérimentations et
c'est pour cette raison que j'ai rappelé
les deux années 24 et 25 c'est la date
de ces années là qu'on pourra évaluer
véritablement le la façon dont on
utilisera batterie ou hydrogène pour
remplacer l'électrification on peut vous
communiquer bien évidemment le surcoût
de la batterie ou le surcoût de
l'hydrogène le surcool l'hydrogène
embarquant d'autres sujets qui sont
comment remplir nos véhicules et comment
les approvisionne mais je pense que
votre question
mérite d'être éclairée il faut que par
écrit on puisse répondre à ces questions
et par ailleurs vous avez relevé les
pourcentages que j'ai donné dans mon
propos introductif oui les pourcentages
que j'ai donné qui étaient locataires
prend en compte les 16% de circulation
carbonée
merci sur un porteur
une dernière question avant d'ici la
parole à mes collègues quand vous êtes
sur enfin les bio-carburants vous êtes
soyons clairs sur la ce qu'on appelle
nous la première génération de carburant
donc vous êtes bien sur l'idée que vous
allez utiliser cette première génération
pendant une étape que je comprends comme
relativement longue
donc où est-ce que vous en êtes
aujourd'hui de la capacité à vous
approvisionner avec cette filière là
parce que c'est important quand même
très grand client comme comme SNCF et ce
point de vue là et est-ce que vous avez
une idée des volumes est-ce que voilà ce
que ça fait déjà l'objet d'une
discussion comme on est dans une période
de de entre guillemets de planification
c'est le mot à la mode sur ces questions
là comme la PPE va arriver
et comme on nous dit aussi parfois alors
c'est discuté que la biomasse c'est pas
non plus facile à trouver qui aura
peut-être une limite et voilà est-ce que
à votre avis ça ça voilà vous avez
assuré cette approvisionnement
alors en fait le biocarburant donc il y
a on envoie trois sortes il y a le
Bessan qui est
les graines de colza écrasées et
stérifiées et on a de l'huile de colza
qui est donc un coproduit relativement
simple avec des capacités de production
dans des petites unités en région et
l'intérêt c'est que là on est sur un
produit je lui dis simple peut consommer
en fabrication et avec une quantité qui
est déjà disponible on a estimé que la
quantité que l'on pourrait avoir besoin
pour la flotte TER si toute la flotte
basculait du jour au lendemain en
baissant serait de l'ordre de 7% de la
production actuelle de Bessan et comme
je le disais tout à l'heure et à un
moment où les courbes nécessaires en
baissant pour le l'automobile vont se
croiser avec la montée donc on n'a pas
de de problèmes de disponibilité sur le
Besson
pourquoi nous le baissons nous nous
convient et que il est pas forcément
retenu dans d'autres secteurs de
transport l'aviation par exemple c'est
que le produit ne peut pas être utilisé
à des températures inférieures à 15
degrés à -15 s'affiche et le HVO par
exemple lui ne fiche pas avant - 35 - 40
donc d'autres secteurs ne peuvent pas
utiliser le biocarburant bon mais nous
dans l'immédiat on est sur le
biocarburant et qu'on dit que c'est une
période de transition pour nous la
priorité c'est de sortir du diesel et
d'aider les régions à sortir du diesel à
un coût économique et cette période de
transition elle va accompagner le
matériel thermique qui arrivera
progressivement en fin de vie
le HVO on est plus réticent
parce que le process de fabrication est
beaucoup plus complexe on a qu'un site
de production en France par exemple on
sait qu'on aura moins de disponibilités
de HVO et que d'autres secteurs
justement en ont plus besoin et puis
après ce que l'on se dit aussi c'est que
comme vous le mentionnez la biomasse les
déchets sont difficiles à obtenir le
processus c'est consommant en énergie et
donc on n'est pas au même niveau de
maturité que que le Bessan est né en
termes de coût est ni en termes non plus
de
capacité à monter en production avec
cette rareté de biomasse cette
formulation à mettre au point et ce
process complexe et puis les
investissements industriels qu'il faudra
derrière on est sur un délai un peu plus
long et puis le E fuel là c'est vraiment
près de ma c'est pour plus tard et la
consommation en énergie nécessaire pour
faire ce if you le process sera encore
d'un niveau de complexité plus fort que
ce que l'on connaît sur le HBO c'est
c'est pour cela qu'on a mis ses
priorités et que aujourd'hui nous le if
Youle on le met pas dans notre stratégie
de remplacement du diesel
merci Monsieur président Directeur vous
16% c'est 16% quand vous dites
16%, c'est vous avez ramené à des
voyageurs ou
c'est le nombre de
84 alors est-ce que vous voulez dire que
60 % de ce qui est électrique
transporte 84% vous usagers et 40% 16%
exactement
mon collègue Stéphane de
merci monsieur le Président je suis
sénateur de la somme donc des Hauts de
France et je voudrais vous poser deux
questions qui sont liées à ma région
madame vous avez beaucoup parlé du
Besson
les hauts de France c'est
la deuxième ou troisième région
importante en termes de trafic je crois
il y a 1280 trains il y a 200 000
voyageurs par jour enfin c'est vraiment
quelque chose de d'important pour vous
et dans le cadre de votre démarche
planétaire vous avez donc initié une
expérimentation sur le parylan avec du
avec du Besson et cette expérimentation
de mémoire elle devait se terminer fin
2021 donc je veux juste savoir si on
pouvait avoir un premier retour
d'expérience sur une première
appréciation par rapport à cette
expérimentation à la fois sur le plan
financier mais aussi sur le plan
technique est-ce que vous étiez
satisfait de cette de cette
expérimentation la deuxième question
concerne justement et je reviens sur les
propos donc qui ont été tenus à vous
disiez 60% du réseau d'électrifier ce
qui représente 84% j'ai bien compris
donc du transport passager dans les 40%
non électrifiés il y a la fameuse
arlésienne du Paris Boulogne dont on a
beaucoup parlé ces derniers temps et
j'ai cru comprendre je pense que ce sont
des mauvaises langues mais j'ai cru
comprendre que le projet
d'électrification du du ami à Boulogne
était abandonné voilà je voulais juste
savoir si vous aviez quelques
informations sur le sujet je profite de
ce genre de mission d'information pour
faire mes courses en tout cas pour avoir
un peu de d'éclairage quand à la réalité
des des projets
sur le Parisien je vais laisser Stéphane
vous répondre sur le Amiens Boulogne
pour avoir été le patron des trains
intersités effectivement on faisait un
changement à Amiens de locomotive la
bonne nouvelle pour
je parle je reprends donc sur Paris
Boulogne pour avoir été de patron des
trains intercepté pendant quelques
années effectivement un changement de
locomotive qui se faisait à Amiens
depuis on a des matériels automoteurs et
qui est bimode et du coup il y a plus
ces changements là pour répondre à votre
question sur l'électrification de Amiens
Boulogne je ne sais pas vous répondre
mais on va prendre le point et je
demanderai à mon collègue Mathieu
Chabanel de m'aider dans la réponse
écrite que nous vous ferons je ne sais
pas vous répondre mais sur
l'expérimentation le parylan
oui sur l'expérimentation par élan
l'expérimentation a vraiment donné de
très très bons résultats d'ailleurs
comme commandant en Normandie les
résultats sur haute France ont confirmés
ce que nous voulons ce que nous avions
vu aussi sur sur normandie plusieurs
points positifs les performances déjà
nos matériels étaient compatibles donc
ça c'était vraiment le point le point
fort mais on avait déjà une petite
indication parce qu'on avait fait des
tests au bon moteur auparavant on avait
on avait quelques craintes sur la
performance de traction vous savez qu'on
est tenu respecter les horaires cette
performance de traction était au
rendez-vous donc on n'avait pas de on
n'avait pas un une énergie qui était qui
était finalement moins bonne que le que
le diesel elle était aussi au
rendez-vous une sur une surconsommation
attendue là aussi on n'a pas constaté de
surconsommation donc vraiment tous les
voyants étaient ouverts pour le le Paris
Land et effectivement c'est que c'est
une un bon point pour nous sur le en
tout cas le matériel régi puisque
c'était notre matériel le plus moderne
qui circule sur Paris long ça a été un
franc succès
maintenant c'était pour répondre s'il y
a une précédente question il y avait ce
sujet réglementaire aujourd'hui de la
réglementation nous contraint à ne pas
pouvoir de développer le Bessan dans
l'ensemble de nos stations de
distribution la réglementation nous
impose d'avoir des installations
spécifiques pour distribuer le Besson et
ont donc on a deux leviers soit
effectivement on réinvestit dans des
nouvelles installations de distribution
soit on contraint notre schéma
d'exploitation pour pouvoir faire en
sorte que la rame fasse toujours par le
même le même passage de la même station
donc c'est ce sujet aussi qu'il faudra
un autre sens pouvoir faire évoluer pour
que le déploiement du Besson en soit
complètement facilité
merci
Martine Bertin
oui bonjour Martine Berthet c'est une
actrice de la Savoie j'aimerais revenir
sur la solution hydrogène monsieur le
Président Directeur Général
cette solution hydrogène j'ai le
sentiment que nous sommes en que vous
êtes pardon en retard sur le sujet j'ai
eu l'occasion de visiter Alstom Belfort
assez récemment et il m'a semblé
comprendre que l'Allemagne était déjà
dans une expérimentation bien plus
avancée que nous et d'autres pays me
semble-t-il donc est-ce que vous pouvez
revenir sur ce point nous dire pourquoi
nous sommes en retard est-ce que parce
que d'emblée au départ vous n'avez pas
eu confiance dans cette solution
hydrogène ou une autre raison
travaillez-vous déjà sur les
implantations de sites de production
et peut-être pour mon secteur de
montagne quelles sont les solutions que
vous envisagez alors j'imagine pas les
biocarburants mais voilà ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus merci beaucoup
moi
si vous avez visité Alstom
et les solutions avec le leur matériel
roulant qui s'appelle le hellint qui
fonctionne aujourd'hui en Allemagne le
choix qu'on a fait en France on peut pas
tout à fait dire que nous sommes en
retard enfin je veux pas me permettre de
laisser le dire en tout cas nous avons
fait sous l'autorité de Carole de très
gros travaux justement pour développer
l'hydrogène développer l'hydrogène sur
la base de matériel au long que nous
avons à savoir les Régis puisque ce sont
des c'est un parc ça fait partie des
deux parcs que vous avez le Regis et le
réseau de N qui sont les deux parcs de
matériaux en TER qui sont les plus en
pointes et qui répondent à deux besoins
le Regis c'est un seul niveau le régime
c'est deux niveaux pour permettre aux
régions de répondre à leurs questions de
la totalité de leurs attentes en termes
de transport ferroviaire donc avec avec
Alstom et
la direction de Carole nous avons déjà
fait des expérimentations sur
l'hydrogène et nous allons faire cette
expérimentation sur comme je disais mon
propos introduction mon résoluchon sur
l'hydrogène et ce sujet là mérite d'être
adapté au matériel roulant peut-être que
tu peux éclairer soit Carole soit
Vincent
qui a été directement
en retard parce que c'est des travaux
qui ont été avancés et vous ne faites
que reprendre les propos je l'entends
tout à fait
alors le sujet du train hydrogène
présente l'avantage d'une plus grande
autonomie c'est vraiment ce qui nous
motive dans l'idée de développer des
trains hydrogènes c'est train décarboné
avec une grande autonomie
600 600 km quand en batterie aujourd'hui
on est à 80 100 km donc c'est vraiment
l'intérêt le choix qu'on a qu'on a voulu
faire comme comme l'expliquait le
Président fanichet c'est de travailler
sur un autre matériel que leint avec
Alstom et c'est de travailler sur un
train qui est bimode en se disant le
surcoût de l'hydrogène aussi c'est lié à
l'infrastructure les stations de
recharge et donc en transformant un
train à la fois en mode électrique et à
la fois en mode thermique ça nous
permettait de limiter les stations de
rechargement sachant que de toutes les
manières il y avait un
coût d'adaptation et un temps de
développement pour adapter le train
ilint au réseau français qui était aussi
long que la solution que l'on a retenue
et qui nous permettait d'avoir un train
qui était plus polyvalent
je vais dire quelques mots merci pour la
question la cicatrice alors en effet on
est sur cette question de l'hydrogène
avec les régions depuis 2018 donc ça
fait quelques années en effet on a déjà
eu un temps je pense ils vont de le
rappeler aussi qui a été de pouvoir
passer cette première commande et en
effet on est parti sur une vision qui
est vraiment de tester en opérationnel
sur une première sur un premier parc
parce qu'on est sur 12 12 trains 12 de
ce matériel région lisse donc quatre
régions comme comme cela était rappelé
et quand on parle de cette première
expérimentation qui est se fera
évidemment dans les conditions
opérationnelles ça veut dire aussi pas
simplement de réfléchir sur sur les
questions du train mais aussi sur tous
l'écosystème un des points central qu'on
doit évoqué c'est évidemment la question
de la distribution la production et la
distribution d'hydrogène et aussi
l'adaptation de la performance de
l'engin aux différents parcours qu'il va
pouvoir rencontrer donc on a un travail
qui a été un travail avec les régions
assez proches de travail sur toutes les
dimensions avec Alstom sur évidemment la
production de ce train là avec quelque
chose qui est un peu différent bien sûr
intégré une solution hydrogène et une
solution qui reste relativement complexe
sur lequel évidemment les aspects de
sécurité sont centraux mais on l'a aussi
pensé dans le cadre un peu plus lointain
de se poser la question si de la
modification du matériel existant donc
c'est à la fois être en capacité
d'acheter ces régisses neufs en mode
hydrogène mais aussi à moyen terme
d'avoir aussi des kits de modifications
et de rétrophytes en complément c'est
aussi un impact sur la définition de nos
plans de transport sur la maintenance
associée à ces trains et j'allais dire
que cette vision assez holistique et
cette approche systèmes que nous avons
sur l'hydrogène nous permet d'adresser
tous les éléments et vous avez vu dans
la presse récemment les difficultés
aussi qui sont actuellement exprimés du
côté allemand
justement parce que la segmentation de
l'ensemble des des briques
technologiques
est assez difficile à consolider et
aujourd'hui on a cette approche
complètement système c'est à dire à
savoir évidemment faire rouler un train
hydrogène en sécurité mais aussi savoir
le maintenir et surtout savoir
l'alimenter alors je m'arrête 2 secondes
sur cette question de l'alimentation qui
est au cœur du sujet
on voit bien aujourd'hui que la
problématique elle a été exprimée par le
président
elle se situe au niveau du prix
où il y a eu au sein de cette commission
plusieurs expressions sur des prix
d'hydrogène le prix d'hydrogène on
serait bien quand on parle d'hydrogène
des carbonée c'est aussi le prix de
l'électricité mais c'est aussi le prix
de l'acheminement du transport les
grandes infrastructures de distribution
d'hydrogène aujourd'hui n'existe pas
donc si on parle de production massifiée
sur des grands centres de production par
des grands énergéticiens il faut
l'acheminer jusqu'au train et entre le
prix de sortie d'usine et le prix à la
pompe on a un différentiel qui est non
négligeable donc ça c'est le premier
élément le deuxième c'est aussi
travailler à une uniformisation
des aspects systèmes sur l'ensemble des
régions il faudrait pas qu'on se
retrouve à avoir des stations de
distribution dans une région qui soit
pas compatible avec le train qui circule
bref on a une vision complètement
holistique sur l'ensemble du territoire
pour une circulation on se prépare et ça
a été dit tout à l'heure au-delà de
l'expérimentation avoir être prêt à
déployer ces conditions économiques sont
réalistes assez rapidement cette
solution cette solution l'a dit elle est
vraiment complémentaire à ce qu'on va
faire sur la batterie de par l'autonomie
600 km aujourd'hui demain on pense qu'on
peut encore aller plus loin on a
développé aussi ça a été dit un train
bimode parce que pourquoi la
problématique de l'hydrogène c'est
l'autonomie c'est son stockage aborder
train on voit bien que ça c'est une
limite physique
là où on a déjà et on a exprimé le taux
d'électrification en France là on a déjà
une caténaire autant l'utiliser pour
essayer de d'utiliser au minimum
l'hydrogène la bonne escient là où c'est
nécessaire donc pour répondre très
précisément à votre question
on n'est pas forcément en retard on a
juste une approche qui est vraiment
d'être prêt à déployer et à passer à
l'échelle et aussi d'intégrer toutes ces
briques technologiques y compris là
maintenant c'est la redéfinition des
plantes de transport donc une vision
réaliste c'est fin 2025 les premières
circulations et à la fin de l'année 2026
l'ensemble des douze RAM région lisses
pourront circuler
et pour répondre à la question de
qu'est-ce qu'on peut mettre comme train
des carboné dans les régions de montagne
donc on mettra pas le baissant à cause
des -15 mais par contre on pourrait
mettre du HVO des batteries ou de
l'hydrogène
[Musique]
oui merci monsieur le Président deux
questions
quand j'écoute vos propos je comprends
que les biocarburants c'est une solution
transitoire mais qui ne sera pas durable
et à l'horizon 2050 où on doit aller
vers le zéro émission
vous cherchez vous cherchez une autre
solution pour pour faire face alors je
voulais juste la précision sur sur ce
point là le second
vous ne dites que vous allez vers une
industrie verte que c'est le meilleur
moyen de transport qui émet le moins de
missions de carbone
ça va dans l'air du temps avec la
volonté du citoyen pourquoi vous n'avez
pas un billet de train qui va en
augmentation par rapport à par rapport à
cette forme qui est fait
merci pour répondre à la deuxième
question merci pour votre question pour
la deuxième question en un mot ce que
vous proposez c'est de une réflexion qui
pourrait être au travers d'une fiscalité
ou d'une taxe suivant le mode carboné ou
des carboné aujourd'hui on parle les
trains qui aujourd'hui
sont l'objet de nos discussions sont les
trains régionaux aujourd'hui il y a
aucun train nationaux qui circule au
gazole on parle bien des trains
régionaux et aujourd'hui il appartient
je dirais à chacune des autorités
organisatrices de transport de décider
de la modalité et des taxes qui
pourraient mettre en fonction des modes
utilisés donc cette question est tout à
fait pertinente mais là pour le coup
l'opérateur que nous sommes peut pas y
répondre ça va établement à l'autorité
organise ils ont décidé pour revenir sur
le premier point
il y a trois temps on le redit le Besson
il est pas pérenne mais il est pour
autant tant qu'on n'a pas mieux je pense
qu'il faut quand même mieux tenir que
courir comme dirait la fable donc sur ce
sujet là le Besson répond mais bien à la
question et puis ensuite suivant le
profil de voir je trouvais que c'était
important tel que ça a été rappelé par
mes collègues il y a deux de
possibilités en un mot c'est des petits
parcours
entre deux entre deux points qui font
entre 60 et 80 km et la batterie
répondra à cette question avec une
capacité pour nous potentiellement de
recharger à très haut débit et très
rapidement et puis pour les longs
parcours effectivement c'est l'hydrogène
et c'est deux seuls modes aujourd'hui
qui permettent de répondre à la question
complètement décarbonée de 2050
et je pourrais juste rajouter que on
travaille aussi à redéfinir une une
gamme complète de train pour les petites
lignes les lignes avec moins de clients
avec des trains qui seraient peut-être
moins capacitaires mais qui permettrait
d'avoir plus de fréquence de redonner
vie à des lignes qui n'étaient plus
exploitées et
cette trace serait nativement avec
batterie ou après à hydrogène mais
l'intérêt de la batterie dans le
ferroviaire c'est intéressant parce que
on va pas avoir une course à l'autonomie
comme c'est dans l'automobile nous notre
enjeu c'est vraiment d'avoir une
recharge rapide on récupère l'énergie au
freinage et comme le train va s'arrêter
souvent il va récupérer l'énergie et
puis si on a des points de recharge
rapide en gare on peut viser une
autonomie de 200 km et donc les techno
de batterie vont augmenter les trains
vont vont s'adapter en terme de
conception et
en fait il faut déjà qu'on passe tout le
cap des matériels existants à adapter à
transformer à faire évoluer en carburant
et puis si on se projette à plus long
terme on repense plus en profondeur le
ferroviaire
juste une précision aussi sur le train
batterie on peut même envisager de
coupler ça de l'électrification
partielle pour pouvoir étendre le champ
du train batterie aujourd'hui
l'autonomie de 80 km demain peut-être de
200 km et bien si on arrive à
électrifier uniquement les les sections
du réseau simple à électrifier alors
dans ces cas-là on arrive aussi à avoir
des trains à batterie qui peut faire de
plus amples une plus ample distance une
plus grande distance donc ça aussi c'est
une solution que l'on garde
merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
Président merci pour vos éclairages
moi je poserai une question un petit peu
à l'aune de ce qui fait débat un petit
peu aujourd'hui
j'écoute beaucoup les déclarations
officielles de la SNCF
qui manque pas d'ailleurs de pointer des
mots d'un peu plus polluants en disant
peut-être pourrait-il être plus
contributeur qu'il ne le sont
suivez mon regard
et cet après-midi de la complexité du
sujet quand même auquel nous sommes tous
confrontés même s'il est vrai que
personne ne conteste les vertus du
transport ferroviaire il n'est pas moins
vrai quand même que le transport
ferroviaire ne vit pas seulement de
l'air du temps il ne se développe pas
par les effets de la générosité de la
génération spontanée
donc vous êtes tributaire aussi des
investissements des à
si les aos n'investissent pas très
difficile donc outre les recommandations
utiles que vous faites et elles sont
précieuses
vous êtes quand même également dépendant
de la capacité pour les collectivités de
relever le défi auquel notre société nos
sociétés humaines sont confrontées
et puis alors il y a un deuxième sujet
qui me trotte dans la tête pardonnez-moi
de l'exprimer ainsi c'est que
le ferroviaire et le seul mode qui paie
tous ses coups
enfin moi je le lis comme ça vous payez
votre énergie
et pas au prix le plus bas
vous payez des péages que lorsque vous
utilisez l'infrastructure ferroviaire
financée par un peu tout le monde y
compris par votre propre groupe qui
contribue
donc évidemment faut passer tonner du
résultat c'est que
le mode ferroviaire est toujours trop
cher
d'ailleurs il arrive que vous essuyez le
reproche
qui ne se reproche qui au fond n'est pas
très fondé dans la mesure où vous êtes
tributaire de décision qui sont prises
par d'autres
alors j'ai une question
que vous répondons lorsque vous dites
que le ferroviaire et le seul mode qui
paye tous ses coups
monsieur
comment vous répondre à cette question à
la fois
plus que pertinente
mais pour autant
pour le dirigeant que je suis dans cette
entreprise à la fois très compliqué à
répondre
et vu d'ailleurs vous avez d'ailleurs vu
le temps que je mets à reformuler votre
question
non mais aujourd'hui enfin
cette phrase elle aurait pu être
prononcée de ce côté de la table
mais lorsqu'on est le groupe SNCF c'est
toujours plus difficile de l'exprimer
même si je partage entièrement ce que
vous venez de dire mais aujourd'hui pour
un groupe comme le nôtre parce que je
voudrais que vous ayez pu retenir c'est
qu'effectivement le mode ferroviaire il
est déjà massivement décarboné
aujourd'hui
au moment où tous les Français se posent
la question de la décarbonation vous
avez devant vous nous mais notre groupe
est déjà décarboné et entre guillemets à
84% si je prends un chiffre pour en
prendre un parce que N dans les nombreux
chiffres que je vous ai donné nous
pensons que les solutions et les
bouquets de solutions que nous pouvons
apporter sont un chemin solide et
robuste pour aller vers la décarbonation
et non pas en étant en exprimant des
voeux mais avec des solutions matures
la batterie avec les régions l'hydrogène
avec les régions sont déjà des
expérimentations qui qui fonctionnaient
le mérite d'être améliorée peut-être que
notre groupe
est peut-être trop timide en exprimant
le fait que lui les décarbonée à
84% si je reprends ce chiffre là mais
effectivement nous payons tous nos coups
et surtout je dirais que c'est pas nous
qui payons tous nos coups mais ce sont
les voyageurs ou les autorités
organisatrices
les seuls voyageurs qui payent tous
leurs coups c'est ceux qui sont dans les
TGV effectivement puisque il paye aussi
bien les péages que l'ensemble des coûts
afférents au billet de train et pour
autant je me permets puisque je suis
devant vous aujourd'hui que la loi que
qui a été votée en 2018 et qui s'exécute
en 2020 à la particularité
d'être je dirais
une boucle généreuse puisque 100% de ce
qui est produit dans le ferroviaire ou
100% de l'économie qui est produit dans
le ferroviaire reste dans le ferroviaire
il y a assez peu de groupes comme le
nôtre qui se pose la question la
décarbonation et qui dans le même temps
grâce à la loi
permet d'avoir un cercle vertueux ou
tout ce qui est généré dans ce groupe
reste dans le ferroviaire et merci
monsieur le sénateur de m'avoir donné
l'occasion de le réexprimer en vous en
remerciant Vincent
oui une dernière question excusez-moi je
reprends la main c'est je reviens à mes
biocarburants qui sont sur une durée
limitée d'un point de vue industriel
comment on va pouvoir développer une
technologie qui est quand même
relativement coûteuse et l'amortir sur
un temps si court
on est entièrement d'accord c'est pour
ça déjà que nous notre priorité c'est le
Besson le Bessan on l'a dit il est en
surcapacité il est disponible il va y en
avoir de plus en plus au fur et à mesure
que le besoin routier va baisser et donc
c'est pour ça que notre priorité nous
dans les biocarburants c'est déjà de
regarder comment pouvoir développer à
coup économique puisque techniquement
c'est ça pose pas de problème à la fois
en production et à la fois l'utilisation
comment trouver des incitations fiscales
et nous permettent d'utiliser le Besson
et réserver le HVO pour des utilisations
spécifiques parce que là effectivement
c'est plus compliqué à développer et
puis je reviens même pas sur le if
you'll qui est pour moi encore l'étape
d'après demain
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voulais rebondir l'excellente question
de notre collègue Laennec avec Julie
peut-être une toute petite nuance et que
il me semble que le ferroviaire n'est
pas le seul secteur à payer ses coûts je
pense que l'aérien paye ses coups même
son administration et en l'occurrence la
DGAC et le contrôler aérien y compris
l'investissement les matériels
nécessaires et investissement important
nécessaire au contrôler rien mais bon
c'est pas l'essentiel par contre je
voudrais l'inverse dire que il y a un
débat aussi sur la contribution attendue
des autres modes en faveur du
ferroviaire voilà là-dessus vous avez
été assez pudique mais je voulais
peut-être vous inviter à nous dire
comment vous voyez cet aspect là
extrêmement simplement
je il me semble que le gouvernement
c'était je vais y arriver
il me semble que le gouvernement s'est
exprimé sur ce sujet tant que en tant
que groupe public
souscrivons à ce qui était prononcé par
le gouvernement
moi je voulais simplement avoir une
votre matériel il a une durée de vie sur
le long terme et donc changer de mode de
carburant ou
quel que soit l'énergie ça veut dire que
vous allez changer votre matériel
comment vous l'avez programmé comment ça
se passe
alors permettez-moi de revenir un tout
petit peu en arrière sur les matériels
roulants en ce moment les deux matériels
roulants que nous devons pour les
régions c'est de nature le régurice et
le régime ces matériaux roulants
aujourd'hui ils ont la capacité de
souhaites électriques soit d'être bimode
puisque peuvent être égazois et
électrique ce que l'on ouvre aujourd'hui
c'est la capacité de lui donner entre
guillemets un troisième voire un
quatrième mode c'est troisième et
quatrième mode c'est quoi c'est les
batteries ou l'hydrogène sur le gazole
tel que je les dis aujourd'hui le gazole
c'est une adaptation pour quelques
milliers d'euros on passe au Bessan donc
c'est pas un gros investissement le
sujet c'est la disponibilité du
carburant sa fiscalité et le caractère
réglementaire sur lequel je ne
reviendrai pas après c'est la batterie
ou l'hydrogène un matériel roulant
de train est un matériel qui est
lorsqu'on l'achète avec les régions et
pour les régions c'est un matériel
roulant qui est là pour une quarantaine
d'années aujourd'hui d'ailleurs sur deux
matériaux roulants qui sont largement
déployés dans les régions à savoir la GC
le TER de zng nous sommes à ce qu'on
appelle une opération mi-vie une
vingtaine d'années
notre objectif c'est d'arriver à bien
viser pour que
au moment on fait cette opération de
midi à 20 ans on est pu être à
l'intérieur cette nouvelle technologie
batterie ou hydrogène
et donc ça sera bien une adaptation de
matériel roulant et non pas acheter de
nouveaux matériels roulants
ça c'est pour la flotte qui existe déjà
c'est à dire les régions ont massivement
investies c'est pas le groupe SNCF c'est
les régions qui ont payé tous ces
matériaux ils ont massivement investi
donc on va ce qu'on appelle rétrophyter
ou faire des opérations midi ça c'est en
cours de ce qui se fera et les décisions
comprendra en fonction sur batterie ou
hydrogène et le deuxième sujet c'est que
une fois que la technologie batterie ou
hydrogène sera au point voilà livraison
des nouveaux matériels roulants seront
livrés avec cette nouvelle technologie
voilà comment on voit le matériel blanc
la chance qu'on a dans le mode
ferroviaire c'est que nos matériaux
un long moment c'est 40 ans c'est
valable pour l'ensemble des matériaux
Transilien ou que ce soit du TGV les
seuls matériels concernés par cette ce
sujet de décarbonation sur les terres et
donc ces trois modes là c'est bon
correspondent aux trois temps qui sont
les temps biocarburant sur les 60%
batterie sur les je dirais les
géographies qui nous permettront de le
faire avec comme la rappeler à mes
collègues un principe d'électrices
d'électrification pardon frugal ça veut
dire qu'on mettra juste des bouts de
caténaire là où il sera nécessaire que
les batteries se rechargent et enfin le
mode qui est entre guillemets 10 fois
plus performant entre guillemets
c'est l'hydrogène mais avec toute la
complexité de sa distribution
et de l'infrastructure dans son
dispositif donc j'espère que l'ensemble
de mes collègues on vous aura prouvé que
entre guillemets on est prêt il y a des
solutions pour aujourd'hui il y a des
préparations pour demain batterie et
hydrogène qui pose un certain nombre de
questions mais qui sont des questions
entre guillemets solubles
et qui sont entre guillemets assez
facilement
facile à instruire on n'est pas sur des
technologies qui sont naissantes on est
sur des choses qui sont déjà solides
l'hydrogène tout le monde se sait
comment fonctionne une pile à hydrogène
et ce sujet n'existe pas depuis hier la
complexité c'est sa distribution
le sujet c'est son infrastructure qui va
avec mais la technologie de l'hydrogène
existe depuis très très longtemps
aujourd'hui donc voilà les matériaux
entre guillemets ils existent déjà on
les adaptera pour quelques milliers
d'euros lorsqu'on parle du Besson et
sans doute pour plusieurs autres
milliers d'euros sur les batteries
est-ce que je me permettrais de faire
c'est qu'on puisse vous dites indicatif
ce qu'est une opération pour mettre des
batteries à l'intérieur ou pour mettre
de l'hydrogène
merci
est-ce que
plus personne monsieur rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président oui je vais
peut-être dire une horreur mais je
m'assuré que le débat est clos ou du
moins qu'il est circonscrit
la question des bus à la place des
petites lignes
où est-ce que vous en êtes enfin je suis
obligé de vous poser la question ici on
aime les territoires on aime on aime
desservir les territoires des enclavés
donc qui ont on ne voit jamais des
gaieté de coeur l'idée qu'une petite
ligne pourrait s'arrêter donc je suis
clair dans mon propos mais pour autant
je me dois de vous poser la question
est-ce que c'est considération
environnementale peuvent vous pousser
parfois à dire non sur telle ligne ça
voudra pas la peine
et il vaut mieux passer à des bus
des carbonées
alors la question est tout à fait
pertinente et vous l'avez fait
d'ailleurs à des saints
aujourd'hui il y a des lignes qui sont
très circuler et on sait que le mode
ferroviaire sur des lignes très circuler
en portant de nombreux passagers et la
meilleure des solutions aussi bien en
bilan énergétique que même en bilan de
frottement puisque comme chacun sait sur
le rail on est deux fois 7 fois si je me
trompe pas plus performant sur le rail
que sur la route mais ça c'est lorsqu'on
transporte beaucoup de passagers nous ce
que l'on pense
c'est qu'il y a un autre mode et c'est
ce que évoquer à l'instant Carole
Denault avec les petites lignes
aujourd'hui on a une infrastructure
ferroviaire il faut que nous regardions
si cette structure ferroviaire peut
répondre à ce qu'on appelle des desserts
fines du territoire la réponse est oui
aujourd'hui nous avons grâce aux équipes
de Caroline et du groupe de façon
globale développer dans l'innovation et
sur nos propres budgets
la possibilité de mettre d'autres
véhicules sur ces voies ferrées c'est ce
qu'on appelle Flexi et résine
[Musique]
sur ce sujet là parce que ce sont des
petits véhicules parce que aujourd'hui
un TER le plus petit que l'on est c'est
pour déplacer un minima 80 passagers et
donc aujourd'hui vous avez raison il y a
des bus à 50 donc pour quelle raison on
ferait pas du bus au milieu nous on
pense qu'il y a sur le voient sur le
ferroviaire encore de la possibilité de
faire des plus petits mobiles qui
répondent à cette question en revanche
je vais pas me couper à cette question
le ferroviaire va pas partout
et l'objectif du groupe SNCF c'est de
pas être pas d'aller partout et donc le
bus ou le quart peut répondre en
complémentarité du ferroviaire mais nous
notre intime conviction c'est faux du
rabattement et il faut que le
ferrovienne de soit la colonne
vertébrale des déplacements et que le
mode routier en soit le complémentaire
et oui bien sûr et c'est des autorités
organisatrices n'ont décidé généralement
c'est ce qu'elles font en disant bah
voilà c'est plus flexible de temps en
temps ou tout simplement bah il y a pas
de gare et on va pas tirer des de la
voie ferrée aujourd'hui la voie ferrée
il faut se concentrer sur l'existant et
améliorer l'existant à mon sens il faut
trouver le complémentaire avec le
routier
et vraiment l'intérêt c'est de garder
certaines petites lignes et de les
opérer avec des trains plus petits c'est
justement de garder cette interconnexion
donc il faut qu'on améliore des trains
qui sont plus adaptés en capacité il
faut aussi qu'on améliore l'information
voyageur pour leur garantir les
connexions et il faut qu'on améliore
notre offre de service au sens large
dans une vision
intermodalité comme comme le disait
Christophe Fanny
sur les rupteurs de charge exactement
parce que il reçoit la guerre de la
Part-Dieu comme il y avait quelques
problèmes sur la ligne TGV on peut dire
que l'attente dans la guerre de la
Part-Dieu pour les voyageurs étaient
quand même en dessous de tout voilà je
vous le dis
parce qu'à 20h dans cette guerre tout
est fermé quoi donc voilà mais je suis
d'accord avec vous s'il y a plusieurs
modes le point faible me semble-t-il
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on travaille pas
assez sur les ruptures de charge pour le
voyage
Paris ça c'était relativement bien passé
on a eu de la chance
oui micro question mais qui est pas qui
est pas un micro sujet vous avez assisté
c'est légitime effectivement
sur le l'importance du dialogue avec les
régions notamment sur l'acquisition du
matériel alors bon il y a plein de
raisons à tout ça j'en mets pas à cause
de ce système mais est-ce que pour vous
c'est pas un facteur de complexité parce
que finalement plutôt que d'avoir une
politique nationale et une relation avec
des industriels qui soient peut-être un
peu plus globalisante comment ça se
passe d'abord est-ce que les régions
quand elles voient la note gonfler
comment ça se passe on le dialogue avec
vous c'est pas forcément des
répercussions comment vous vivez ce
dialogue là et est-ce qu'il y a besoin
de fournir en cadre nous on est très
soucieux de liberté territoriales donc
on n'est pas surtout pas forcément de
vendeur mais voilà quel est votre écho
sur ce point
d'abord plusieurs plusieurs éléments
dans ma réponse le premier sujet c'est
que aujourd'hui
les régions au travers de région de
France mais chacune des régions une à
une
ont décidé de confier à SNCF voyageur
le sujet de l'acquisition des matériels
roulants
de nous le confier en tant que quoi en
tant que maîtrise d'ouvrage justement
pour répondre à cette question qui est
achetons ensemble
définissons ensemble les besoins
et essayons pendant toute la durée de
vie du matériel au lendemain les 40
années d'avoir une flotte homogène parce
que aujourd'hui ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que grâce à cette décision qui ont
été pris par les régions de nous confier
cette maîtrise d'ouvrages dans chacune
des régions et bien ça nous permet par
exemple de se prêter de matériel roulant
entre les différentes régions parce que
on peut certaine en achète un peu plus à
un moment donné mais on va avoir des
besoins plus tard ça permet d'avoir une
flotte homogène et aujourd'hui les
régions le dernier contrat qu'on a passé
avec Alstom et Bombardier maintenant
c'est le même entreprise mais Alstom est
bombardier c'était matériel roulant un
niveau très jolis et matériel roulant de
niveau région de zen et Bombardier et
avec ces deux matériels roulants on a
défini avec les régions pour pouvoir
répondre à toutes leurs questions
trafic faible voire très faible et voir
un trafic très important et c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça qu'avec les régions
on a défini quatre profils de ligne ce
qu'on appelle les cities c'est à dire ce
qui fait tout autour des des grandes
métropoles des lignes qu'on appelle
proxy qui vont un tout petit peu plus
loin dans le dispositif puis chrono et
Chronoplus Chronoplus étant les lignes
de longues distances comme on peut la
voir par exemple dans la région de
Normandie puisqu'on parlait du Bessan
tout à l'heure avec le Paris Granville
double paris-can Cherbourg et donc mais
sous le sous l'autorité la bienveillance
du sénateur Laennec je pense que ce mode
de fonctionnement a été un mode de
fonctionnement qui a permis deux choses
la première
de d'avoir la définition unique pour
l'ensemble des régions de deux types de
matériel parce que c'est mieux d'avoir
des flottes
importantes plutôt d'avoir plusieurs
petites flottes d'abord en maintenant ça
vous coûte moins cher et surtout avant
tout en développement ce qui coûte très
cher c'est de développer un nouveau
matériel roulant et ce développement
matériaux lent il est payé par les
régions donc plus il est faible ce qu'on
appelle les coûts fixes et mieux c'est
donc pour le développement c'est comme
ça qu'on s'est entendu avec les régions
deuxième sujet sur la maintenance
lorsqu'on a les mêmes matériels au long
même si c'est pas tout à fait les mêmes
profils de voix madame la sénatrice
c'est vrai que en montagne on consomme
pas tout à fait du carburant ou un
profil de ligne différents mais ça
permet des profils de maintenance
différents et puis surtout ça permet une
mutualisation des coûts à toutes les
étapes développement mais également au
moment de la maintenance et aujourd'hui
c'est un élément je pense de force que
nous avons eu en France par rapport à
d'autres pays vous avez de multiplicité
de gamme de matériellement ou
l'interopérabilité est quand même très
compliqué à faire donc non nous on
trouve que ça a été plutôt gage de
d'économie
et gage plutôt de d'une bonne
performance aussi bien économique que je
dirais de qualité de service
très bien plus de plus personne demande
bien monsieur le Président Directeur
mesdames messieurs merci de nous avoir
accordé de votre temps et merci de votre
éclairage et bonne continuation
voilà merci infiniment comme beaucoup de
Français dans ma famille on a forcément
quelqu'un qui a eu la chance de
travailler à la SNCF je le lis comme ça
merci infiniment